police in Florida captured a gunman
overnight who opened fire at a Golf
Resort owned by President Trump the
suspect was arrested after exchanging
fire with officers police say he was
ranting about the president and well
will Harkins is at the Trump national
Doral Golf Club near Miami man well good
morning good morning police say they
arrived here at about 1:30 this morning
after getting a call about an active
shooter in the lobby of the resort's
hotel police say they confronted that
person who was armed with a handgun and
then there was an exchange of gunfire
the suspect was shot in multiple times
in the lower extremities and officer
suffered a broken wrist video after the
shooting appears to show the suspect
conscious while being wheeled on a
stretcher the suspect was allegedly
ranting about president Trump and had
draped a u.s. flag over a counter police
believe he tried to lure them to the
scene and a fire alarm had been set off
this Resort was purchased by the Trump
Organization back in 2012 the FBI will
be involved in this investigation
Homeland Security has also been on the
scene we should note of course that
President Trump was at the White House
at the time of this shooting John Manuel
thanks